I'm going to keep my remarks brief this
evening I think a visit by Albert
Hoffman to America the foundation of a
library that bears his name that will
serve as an archive for the research
that has been locked away in filing
cabinets and packing boxes for 30 years
and in concert with the political
situation in the society the larger
society around us is a sufficient reason
for causing for a moment and actually
considering what is the psychedelic
experience what promise does it hold for
a sane future for our planet and our
children and what is it about it that
Kindles the kind of loyalty that I feel
coming from the people in this room this
evening and I submit to you that it is
nothing less than the rebirth of a voice
that has been silent for East a thousand
years the still small voice of the love
ghosts of the planet you know the old
testament says you don't have to study
the difference between good and evil
you'll know it the still small voice in
your heart elicits the correct way to
live and in Western culture this still
small voice has been stilled for over a
millennia and we have operated in a
world that is reductionist Objectivist
materialistic secular male dominated
stressing stasis stressing the mine in
particulars in favor of the great
overarching picture and in some way we
have lost our way and it remained for
Giants of 20th century thought like
Freud annealing to announce the
startling fact that there was
a human unconscious and then it took
still a different generation of
researchers with a different set of
analytical skills to take the concepts
of the unconscious and turn it in to a
frontier full of challenge to a
topological manifold that courageous
minds could sail out into to map and to
explore and squarely then in the path of
the materialist reductionist
crypto-fascist dreams of high-tech
industrialism there emerge
there emerged a mystery the last thing
you would expect a true mystery
now dr. Hoffman has been lauded here
this evening for his invention of LSD
certainly this is what he will be
remembered for over the long centuries
ahead but as a matter of fact he is a
thinker of extreme breaths and deaths it
was he working with Carl ruck and Gordon
Watson who proposed that it was actually
psychoactive forgot alkaloids that lay
behind the ilis in Ian's mysteries and
thereby rub the nose of classical
scholarship in the fact that the
foundation and the wellspring of the
Western imagination which was the
mystery cults of ancient Greece that
that foundation is firmly rooted in a
psychedelic experience but when we leave
these things behind we leave behind our
cultural birthright no less than when
the Amazonian Indian deserts his home
village for the sawmills we too were
once tribal people who lived in the
light of mysteries that came to us
mediated by shamans and created out of
the magic of the natural world it was
Albert Hofmann
synthesized still a siphon for the first
time and described its absolute
structural characteristics this is a man
who is astride both the synthetic and
natural product chemistry of the 20th
century like no one else his research
has revealed the unexpected fact that
there are biodynamic alkaloids in our
environment in our feed chain indeed in
our history the argue that we are the
bearers of the great promise that the
future of consciousness can be endlessly
bright in the future it will be
unimaginable
the government's once regulated the
substances that people use to explore
personal growth it is the mark of a
barbarous culture and we are here to
raise the light to say truth is not so
easily swept aside one doesn't just say
no to truth
truth
truth requires engagement it requires
courage it requires a sense of where we
have been and of where we are going